hello freak [ __ ] in my opinion oh and
I come from a certain era I give that to
people you know there's a new era of
kids and I don't [ __ ] on them or hate
them they have this whole thing hating
on these kids calling it mumble rap and
I don't I don't really got a problem
with it you know I mean my only problem
is like hey there are certain cats that
are kind of disrespecting the past and
it's like hey bu
be new be different that's cool be what
you want to be but don't [ __ ] [ __ ] on
cats like biggie and I'm not gonna call
out names and I was correct but anybody
who's listening to me and it's really
hip to the game knows there's these
youngsters that are kind of almost
trying to they're almost trying to make
noise by disrespecting and it's like
listen the path that was walked before
you is the only reason you can [ __ ]
wear that [ __ ] cheesy [ __ ] [ __ ]
jewelry you get and [ __ ] act so
ignorant you know mean and go to the Met
Ball and gallon honest when you ain't
nobody and next year you're not going to
be anybody to met that Met Gala you know
I mean you're just this year's [ __ ]
like not a novel I don't know your
business so that's so much the music
game in level they music a [ __ ] on the
older dudes have been around there's a
lot of youngsters that are like don't
know the history and I don't say you
need to know Biggie's every album but
don't [ __ ] come out [ __ ] on big hat
you can't show come on [ __ ] on POC but
if you come out and act like they didn't
exist or you don't know anything about
them that's all for me and when I know
and they're few and far between but
they've made big headlines and that's
why this there seems to be this
disrespectful hate for the young right I
don't got that because listen I always
said like I just don't ever want to
sound like that old [ __ ] bitter dude
right I'll tell you I don't like that
I'm not a fan of that song or that guy
but go do with you I might be old maybe
I don't get what you're doing you know
I'm as I've gotten older I give less of
a [ __ ] about what other people enjoy and
when I was younger I had for some reason
I felt like I had to argue what I enjoy
versus what you enjoy and that doesn't
make any sense anymore
it's like we're all so [ __ ] different
the idea like me people and
personalities vary so much they another
we're all going to like this let me let
me qualify what I was just talking about
actually because really what I was
talking about wasn't young people if you
want to be if I want to be perfectly
clear what I what I was talking about
was people my age that I hear throwing a
lot of hate and a lot of just like just
like
that ain't rapper letting hip-hop rain
maybe not to you but you really just
sound old and bitter yeah I mean let
them kids get theirs you know I mean I
made the record I wanted to make I
didn't try to make a record that
designer or future or any of these cats
that are doing it now would make cuz
that would look stupid I would look like
a thirsty idiot
because that's not what I do that is
what they do to sort of [ __ ] on it is
[ __ ] on them and I don't know them I
don't know anything and honestly I've
heard future records and I've her
designer records and they're not the
worst things I've ever heard I'm just
not a fan
I just don't that's not my thing it's
not garbage and I don't like when I hear
people just call and [ __ ] out for
garbage that isn't garbage if it's
garbage call it garbage like mr.
brainwash or something like that that's
garbage
yeah I mean you know who I'm talking
about I don't know any of these people
but I don't know what you're talking
about you know here's have you decided
no say that was that was that was that
wasn't even cool but no it isn't it's
not at all I don't I'll tell you nothing
I don't know what the [ __ ] going on
the rap world but what I do know whether
rap I'm not what was on my rap you know
you know these like how many were you
talking about
he's an artist answer like fake [ __ ]
street artists and I stole everything he
ever did with a bike for the bank the
bank's people Banksy yeah there may be
at [ __ ] like faked it till he made it
like though that's the wrong time okay
he's garbage dude like that is garbage I
understand that's garbage
yeah I'd like to be offended is there
somebody in collar you know what for you
it's the equivalent of like Carlos
Mencia yeah mr. brainwash
[Applause]
[Music]